(calm music)
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Rollback" our new YouTube only format,
where we share the best evergreen conversations
from our pre-video catalog with all of you.
Today, we're gonna go almost a decade into the past
to bring you episode number 14, 14, from February of 2013,
with friend, incredible athlete,
and even better human, Byron Davis,
aside from being a former USA Swimming National Team member,
American record holder, UCLA, All-American, and Iron Man,
Byron was just three-tenths of a second shy
of also becoming the first African American
to make the USA Olympic Swimming Team.
He remains a role model for countless young athletes
across the country, and is a sought after speaker,
as well as consultant.
He's a gifted, highly dynamic,
and charismatic conversationalist.
And his story of humble beginnings,
Olympic dreams, and service to others is not only inspiring,
it will no doubt leave you motivated to set a new
and committed course towards self-discovery
and personal transformation.
So please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy this window into the early days of the podcast.
(air swooshes)
You know, Byron, I think you have one
of the most inspirational stories
I've ever heard about, personal transformation.
I mean, your life is incredible.
Your story is incredible.
And I'd like to just kind of get into that a little bit.
You wanna talk about that.
Let's hear it.
Well, where do you wanna start?
We can start at birth.
We can start at (laughs).
Start at birth.
Start at the beginning.
You had to overcome quite a bit
to get where you are and I guess
I can start with, when we met,
I mean, well, or when I first became aware of you,
I think the first time I knew who you were,
and it was many years later before we ever met,
but I remember being at a swim meet,
it was like national championships
or maybe junior nationals.
No, I think it was nationals sometime back in the eighties.
And I was there swimming the 200 fly.
Old eighties.
Probably a senior
in high school or something like that.
And you had started to make waves
on the national swimming scene in the sprint events
and the 100 butterfly.
And I think it was at Indian Annapolis.
I don't remember what meet it was,
but I remember walking the deck
with a couple of my swimming teammates
and we had heard of you,
and it was warmups or something,
and you had just jumped out of the pool
and you were walking down the deck,
and my buddy, Brad Jones, and I saw you,
and were like, holy shit, look at that dude, man,
I don't wanna race that guy.
Oh, that's funny.
'Cause, you were
like chiseled out of granite.
I mean, swimmers by nature
are, you know, they're built dudes,
and they're built like inverted pyramids or whatever,
but you were like a standout on the deck.
You were so cut and fit and it was just terrifying.
It's hilarious, that's awesome.
That's awesome.
And then you went on to be extremely successful
as a swimmer and swim at UCLA.
And before we get back into the backstory,
I wanted to just talk a little bit about that.
I mean, you made a solid effort
to try to make the Olympic team
and kind of fell a little bit short
and let's talk about that story a little bit.
Yeah, and actually that's a really good
jump-off point.
Well, back in 1996,
I made the Olympic Trials, made the finals, in fact,
Wharton seated first in the finals.
At that point,
that was-
In the 100 butterfly.
In the 100 butterfly, right.
And at that point that was the fastest recorded
top eight heat in American history.
And who were the other guys that were in that heat?
We had Mark Henderson.
He was my teammate.
I swam with Mark in my club team.
And I mean, he's just phenomenal,
just a lot of great guys,
but every single person in that race had swum faster
than Mark Spitz world record way back in the day.
It was the fastest top eight guys in America at the point.
And this is 1988.
Well, this is 1996.
Oh, 96, okay.
96, for the Atlanta Games.
And that in the prelims,
the preliminary, of course, you swam prelims first
and basically, the top guys from that,
the top eight come back and swim another race.
And then the top two make the Olympic team.
And I swam the race.
Which by the way, not to interject,
but it's brutal, right.
It's like your first or second, or you go home
and elite swimmers are training four or five hours a day.
It's black line mania,
just in the pool all the time or in the wait room.
You show up for that,
you bust your butt and you taper
and you show up at that meet.
And if you have an off,
you could be number one in the world
and undefeated for the last five years
and you show up and you have an off day
or you gotta sniffle and you're not top two.
You not making the team.
Yep, I mean, that's it.
The U.S Olympic Trials for swimming.
I hear this all the time.
All national team athletes say this,
it is a pressure cooker.
And the competition is so thick.
The United States,
we have so much depth in the sport of swimming.
So much depth that many people say that you know what?
The Olympic Trials was tougher
than the actual Olympic Games.
It usually is.
It is right.
It's sort of like you make the team
and then you go and you have a good time,
you still wanna win, you know, whatever.
But it's like there's a huge relief.
It's all about the trials.
Yeah, it's all about the trials.
And so that race at the Olympic Trials,
made the final, and it was a great race.
It was a pivot in my life
and we can get into this a little bit later.
How far ahead were you at the 50 though?
At the 50.
He had the fastest first 25-50 meters
of anybody by far,
it was that back half for you that was tough.
Oh, it was crazy.
Basically, at that time I had clocked
the world's fastest 50-meter butterfly time
going out on my hundred.
So basically, I broke the world record
in the 50-meter butterfly.
Right, it's like breaking
the 100-meter track record and the 200-meter
in the first hundred.
Exactly.
So I went out like gangbusters went out crazy,
and I came back the second half,
big elephant and piano and the whole ceiling,
everything just dropped on my back.
The last 15 meters of the race.
My shoulders, my lungs, everything just collapsed.
I couldn't get my arms outta the water.
It was painful.
And in the process,
three other guys ended up touching me out
and I missed making the Olympic team
by three-tenths of a second.
Three-tenths of a second.
Oh, my gosh.
And it was a heartbreak,
but I'm gonna jump back a little bit,
but then we can move forward.
What the beauty that actually has come out of that race,
Rich, is that what most people don't realize
is I wasn't even supposed to be in that race.
Most people don't realize that they think,
wow, that's a heartbreak.
And to be honest with you, it was,
I mean, I had post-meet depression
and went through dark days of the soul afterward
and woke up and realized that my dreams
of making the Olympic team
and getting on the Wheaties box was done,
it wasn't gonna happen.
But, what I had to realize,
out of that emerged a beautiful story,
that kinda set the course
for the rest of my life.
But before that race, 14 months leading up into that race,
I was two years into my retirement.
I had stopped swimming after college
and I was on my way to law school.
I had interned at a law firm in Philadelphia my senior year.
And I was preparing to take the LSAT, and go and did that.
And I was on my way, but you know what?
That summer, when I interned, I realized,
I was in a legal library pretty much 12 hours a day.
And I had stacks of depositions and a highlighter.
I have no idea what that feels like.
(Byron and Rich laugh out loud)
And all I did was highlight keywords,
key phrases for two attorneys,
pretty much that's what I did.
And then I would do research and just highlight it.
And I was like,
this is not what I wanna do with the rest of my life.
Well, it's amazing you get this college education
and you're sort of prepared for the world
and you kinda step forward and think,
well, this is the upwardly mobile thing to do, right.
And then to kinda walk into that and go,
really, this is it.
This is the big prize.
And after being at the level you were in swimming
and all the excitement and all of that
to be sitting in that office
reduced to a highlighter. (laughs)
It was not fun.
It's a dark moment
of the soul.
I bet you were really
good with that highlighter though, weren't you?
Oh, man, you know what?
I became just a brilliant artist with that highlighter.
I was really,
it was-
You applied that Olympic
prow just right into that highlighting.
I applied excellence
to highlighting
You are.
You're like that in everything you do.
That's great.
But so that summer,
I realized I didn't wanna go to law school.
I didn't wanna do anything that way but at the same time,
I realized I wanted to continue to swim.
I knew in my heart
that I had my best swimming still ahead of me.
Yet, I had to tell my mom,
I had to tell the rest of the world and my social network
and people that I wanted
to get back in the water and train.
But now here,
I'm no longer in college, in the United States,
there's really no professional swimming.
Especially back in 96 and 95
back in the early nineties, you really had to swim overseas
if you wanted to at least survive.
So I definitely, I knew I wanted to swim.
So what I ended up doing was becoming a substitute teacher
in Compton, California.
So I went into the hood and taught English and PE,
and then I decided to start training
with the crosstown rival USC, of course, being from UCLA.
Went to USC that was like unheard of.
But at this point,
had UCLA already decimated their program.
Yeah, UCLA, my senior year in 93
was the last year we had the men's team.
Right, and just for the listener out there,
UCLA was a dynasty in swimming,
in the seventies and the eighties,
and just produced champion after champion
and NC two A championship team one after another.
And it was kind of Title IX
that was the death knell for the program, right.
Which was the law that was passed
that said you had to have equal funding
for women's sports and men's sports.
And so colleges across the country had to start cutting
men's programs or funding more women's programs.
And UCLA ended up cutting its swimming program,
which was devastating to swimming
and still to this day is unbelievable to me.
And it's unbelievable
that they have not resuscitated the program.
We're trying to work on that right now.
The alumni were really working hard.
UCLA just built a beautiful new 50-meter pool
specifically for the competitive aquatics.
So for the Water Polo team and the women's swim,
so, we're trying to really
get in there.
I've seen it,
it's incredible.
And I'm like, there's no men's swim team
to use this facility.
It's unbelievable in Southern California.
Yeah, it's crazy.
But because of that, I decided to start training at USC.
And I had no money and pretty much living
with there were about six guys in an apartment.
I started substitute teaching and training and that's it.
But in that moment, Rich and Julie,
I knew that I was in my sweet spot.
I knew that I was supposed to be there.
I couldn't explain it to other people,
but I knew that I was supposed to be there.
And all I knew was to get up every morning
and train and to make a long story short,
I ran into a friend of mine who was a swimmer,
And then she said, "You know what?
"You need to contact Jonty Skinner,
"because the U.S National team is creating this new
"unprecedented program at the Olympic Training Center,
"the resident national team,
"and they said people who want to,
"the top people, the top swimmers in the world
"are invited to train at the Olympic Training Center.
"You should apply."
Now, I thought that this was gonna be crazy,
because again, here I had never been proven
in the 100-meter butterfly,
so long course was not a strong point for me.
Yeah, But you were a name in the sport.
I mean, it wasn't like you were a nobody,
everybody knew who you were.
Oh, yeah, but again, I had no results.
All my results were yards and in college,
so I'm training, I'm swimming.
I write Jonty Skinner a letter.
I don't even qualify,
my times aren't even fast enough to be a candidate.
And this is where again, we can get into this,
but this is where I really believe providence moves
when we follow our passion, even if we can't explain it.
So I write Jonty Skinner,
the resident national team coach at the time, a letter.
It was September.
I remember it was September 10th.
And I wrote him a letter and just shared it with him,
just listed out an argument.
This is where the whole political science and law came in.
I constructed a great argument
as to why I should be a good candidate.
With a highlighter.
With a highlighter, exactly.
And I wrote him a letter, I sent it off.
September 28th, I get a call from Jonty Skinner.
And literally, I mean, Jonty is one of those guys,
really laid back,
doesn't speak a lot, doesn't say a lot,
says what he means, but pretty monotone.
So you don't know whether-
He's a South African guy, right.
Yeah, South African guy.
He was a great sprinter at the time.
He missed going to the Olympics
because being part of the whole apartheid thing
was the whole issue.
I remember that.
So he really missed his thing,
but became a very accomplished coach
at University of Alabama,
at this time they picked him to be the national team coach
for the resident program.
Wrote him the letter, he calls me September 28th,
and he says, "Byron, just in a nutshell,
"And it's classic.
"I'm not giving you any emotion kinda voice.
"If you are honest about what you put in that letter,
"if you really think you can do
"what you say you think you can do,
"and you're willing to be coachable,
"then I'll see you out here, October 3rd.
Oh, nice.
So that was.
He's got goosebumps.
Oh, and then he hangs up the phone.
I don't even remember him saying goodbye.
It was like click, that was it.
And I'm like, okay, did this just happen?
Is this is real?
And so I was like, "All right."
So I ended up giving pretty much 90% of everything
that I owned away, got out of my lease.
All in one day.
Got out of my lease, packed everything else
that I had in my 1984 Audi 5000
that I bought for 1400 bucks.
And literally, drove out in $50 in my pocket
and drove out to Colorado Springs,
not knowing what was gonna meet me there.
And then in 14 months,
training at the Olympic Training Center
after a two year layoff,
went from never being world-ranked
in a hundred-meter butterfly to being ranked
in the top 10 in the world.
And then coming within three-tenths of a second
of making the Olympic team.
And so that story, (clears throat) I think is the power.
So although I didn't make the Olympic team,
what I draw from that,
that experience was, you know what?
Yeah, I came up a little short,
but failure is never final,
especially if you know how to use it
to fertilize your future success.
And so it took me a while to get that.
But that's what I learned because leading up to that point,
here are all the small wins.
There's a new study out in positive psychology
over the last 10 years.
They stopped studying all the illness in people's heads.
And so they're starting to study,
well, great people who go through tough times.
What makes 'em special?
Well, in positive psychology,
there's the science of small wins,
that's the phrase that they use, the science of small wins,
which is people who are able to truly look at and own
the small wins in their life,
what happens is you start to create a momentum.
Absolutely.
Even if you're going
through tough times and struggles and disappointments
during the times where you're knocked back or knocked down,
that momentum still moves you forward.
So even though you fall, you fall forward.
It's like failing up.
Exactly.
You've had
10 little victories.
And so then you have one setback, you can manage that.
It's not devastating you.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, and the lesson
is that you broke a paradigm
or broke someone else's belief system
about what could be done in your own,
pushed those boundaries and went for it.
And you're actually a champion many times along that path.
Yeah, definitely.
And also I think implicit in that is this idea
that you had an intuitive thought
or an emotional kind of drive that might have defied logic
or was inexplicable, like your swimming career was over
and it was time to get on with life
and you have this nagging feeling.
And I think we're kind of preconditioned in our society
to repress those feelings and my story and my book
and your story is about kind of saying,
no, I'm actually gonna listen to that.
And I don't know where it's gonna lead me.
And it might be crazy and people are gonna tell me,
this is the wrong thing to do,
but you have that something inside you,
that's like pushing you and making that choice
to listen to that and follow those breadcrumbs
wherever they may lead,
I think is really powerful.
Definitely, and here's the thing
I don't wanna harp on what society teaches us,
but we've gotta be honest.
We struggle with in our society,
what I call the gravity of control and comfort,
there is this gravity that continues
to pull us into complacency.
It keeps us safe.
And when we're safe, all it does, it keeps us perpetuating
and moving down the status quo.
And if the status quo, isn't your passion,
isn't something that you're really called to do,
you're doing it for logical reasons
but reasons that don't resonate with your heart,
you start living in this state of quiet desperation
and you start becoming a drone.
And here's the crazy part.
People get really good at becoming drones.
They become very competent and skilled in their profession.
And it then keeps them even more stuck,
because they get a family.
We all go through this, get a family, you have a house,
all these different things you now use
as logical responsible excuses,
not to truly pursue your passion.
And one of the things
that although I didn't learn this lesson,
after the race, it was years later
that I look back on that race,
that the lessons really started to merge for me.
But during that time, after 96,
I floated for a few weeks.
And I just floated, in fact,
I went gotta Dodge, my girlfriend who's now my wife,
my girlfriend and fiance at the time
was playing overseas in Greece.
She was playing pro indoor volleyball in Greece.
And so I decided to just, you know what?
I'm gonna head on over to Greece.
So I convinced my mom to loan me some money.
And I literally hung out in Greece
for two or three weeks.
Yeah, that's cool.
Well, I think that we're also sort of culturally compelled
to sort of make a decision immediately,
like, okay, that chapter ended, what are you doing now?
You need to know immediately and we don't take enough time
to kind of breathe and catch our breath
and go, you know what?
It's okay if I just not make a decision right now
for a little bit and collect myself
and figure out what's next.
I think ultimately it'll set you on a better trajectory
if you allow yourself that space, as opposed to,
oh, my God, this is over.
I need to get a job right away
or go into some kind of tailspin panic over it.
Well, and I wish I could say, Rich, that I knew that.
And I had the courage at that moment to pursue my passion.
My next phase, my next chapter after I got back from Greece,
I was like, "I gotta get a job.
"I gotta get a job."
And so a position opened up to be an assistant coach
at UCLA, but for the women's team
and the head coach at the time
approached me, Cindy Gallagher.
And she said, "I'd love for you to come
"and help me with my sprinters."
And it was a job and it was in something
that I was familiar with, so I ended up taking it.
I gotta tell you five months into the job.
I realized every day I step foot on the pool deck,
I wanted to be in the water.
And I was fighting this thing because it was like,
no, your time is done, you're finished.
But I wanted to be in the pool.
And what I didn't realize
then is I didn't necessarily want to try to reclaim
some glory in the water.
But again, that passion for adventure for expressing myself
kinesthetically for the creative process
that you go through when you're preparing for your event.
All of those things were still fresh inside of me,
yet, I was in a position where my job description
was really clear, and I couldn't move too much
to the left or to the right of that.
I had to stay in that box.
But yet this spirit of creativity and adventure
and wanting to express and use my body
and my mind creatively to produce something, an idea,
that was what was alive in me.
So I struggled.
And pretty soon after a year, I quit,
I wasn't a very good assistant coach.
(Byron and Rich laugh out loud)
And I wasn't doing my job well,
Cindy would've fired me anyway.
So I ended up quitting
and I got back in the water and started training.
What year is this now?
This is now 1998, 1998.
So, here's the thing,
so now I'm married, my wife and I are married.
She decides that she wants to play pro beach volleyball.
And she partnered with a person
who was also new to the game.
And at this point in 1998,
we're married and we live in an apartment
and we decide that both of us were gonna go
for the Olympics again.
And so we go for the Olympics.
That's great.
I start training
and swimming.
I go back to teaching again.
So, this is like, comeback number two.
Comeback number two.
Long story short, I didn't make the 2000 Olympic Games.
My wife did.
Did you make the trials that year?
Yeah, I made the trials, I made the trails.
And I injured my shoulder a couple of weeks before
and I got psyched out.
I mean, that's a whole 'nother story,
but I ended up not making the Olympic team,
but here is the beautiful thing about that moment,
in 1998 again, one of those kernels of confirmation
that's like, you're on the right path.
Stay the course.
So in 98, my wife and I decide
that we're gonna pursue the Olympics,
but we gonna do it full-on.
So we couldn't really work.
So, I quit my job as a substitute teacher,
'cause again, that's what I knew.
I wasn't a coach, said, I can't substitute teach.
I need to focus on swimming.
Annette says, "I need to focus on pro beach volleyball."
Incidentally, she ended up making the Olympic team in 2000.
So we got one Olympian in family, so that's awesome.
But here's again,
here's where that providence comes in.
No later, maybe it was maybe a month later,
we're both into this.
We don't have money and we're wondering what's gonna happen?
I get a call from a casting agent in LA
and they said, "You know what?"
I even forgot,
I forget what company this was, what gaming company,
but they were creating a game
that was revolving around the Olympics,
and the swimming portion was Mark Spitz,
that was the character they were using.
And they wanted to do a commercial with Mark Spitz
and then a backdrop or other swimmers.
So I was an extra in this commercial.
So I get this call, I'm an extra,
I gotta tell you.
They're like we need a black guy.
We need a black guy.
His name is Byron, he's the only one.
(all laugh out loud)
Exactly, we need a black swimmer.
Who can we find?
Yeah, there's only one.
Yeah, exactly.
So we go, and literally, I spend the whole day
and all we're doing are 25s
and I happen to be in the lane
right next to Mark Spitz, right.
And so we're doing this back-
By the way, Mark continues to swim masters at UCLA.
And if you're a master swimmer in Southern California,
you can be on the UCLA masters team
and he still shows up and swims.
And side note, Mark Spitz is hilarious
and he doesn't mean to be that's why he's so funny to me,
because he'll be talking, we'll be swimming and all,
and all of a sudden, he'll tell a story
of how he broke the world record in warmup.
(Julie and Rich laugh out loud)
And he's not boasting.
He's a caricature of himself.
He's almost like a cartoon version of his own personality.
He is, and everything is true.
And you're like, this guy is just a dynamo,
but all of his over-the-top stories are actually true.
He did break the Olympic record in the 200 free
as he was warming up.
It was crazy.
And what year was that?
It was his comeback.
Remember that whole thing.
Yeah, his comeback
is for 92.
It was around the same time.
Oh, it was earlier.
It's from 1992.
So, in fact, we knew each other
'cause he started training with UCLA
and he swam in the sprint lane
from 1990 all the way up to the 1992 Olympic Games,
or at trials.
But I went back to this commercial.
I get the commercial, book the commercial it's done,
to this day, I've never seen the commercial.
Never seen it run on air, but between 1998 and 2000,
I kept getting these nice little checks,
residual checks in the mail, I mean, again,
one day's work paid for my SAG card.
So we got insurance
and we were able to subsist for two years.
That's awesome.
That's amazing.
While we trained.
It was incredible.
It is that crazy magical spiritual equation
that like when you're heart is in alignment
and you're walking purpose and faith
and you don't know where it's gonna lead you,
that you get provided for.
I talk about that in the book
and it seems weird or whatever,
but it's been proven to me so many times in my life.
And then I hear stories like yours all the time.
It doesn't often look like what you think
it's gonna look like.
No, it's never.
You can never predict it,
you don't know what
it's gonna look like.
It's gonna be very
unconventional and very creative,
but it always comes.
And that's what's scary and it's scary,
and if you're human, you get scared by that.
Because again, we're conditioned for comfort and control.
We gravitate toward comfort and control in our lives,
but the creative process it's not control-
It's open.
No, you have
to surrender that control.
You have to be willing to let go
and be willing to receive whatever
is going to come your way.
And you can relate to this, Rich,
just in training for crazy ultra stuff,
there comes a point and we call it being in the zone,
but you reach a point in your race
or your event or whatever it is,
it's a crossroads and that crossroads
you have to make a choice,
either I decide to keep control
and do this through willpower,
or you decide to let go
and you decide to just go into the zone,
you decide to say, you know what?
I'm gonna chase this.
And the pain is still there.
The courage you need to fight through stuff is still there.
All of that, that doesn't go away.
But at some point, you decide to let yourself
be totally captured in the moment,
and then that's where breakthrough happens.
Absolutely.
And I talk about that a lot too.
And the power of surrender and the beauty of surrender
and it's a confusing concept for somebody
who's not familiar with it
because the immediate kind of knee jerk reaction
is, well, that's giving up, like why?
What are you talking about?
I don't understand that.
And I'm like, "That's not what it is at all."
You still take the actions,
you do all the necessary things,
but you're relinquishing your attachment to the results.
You sort of open yourself
up to greater possibilities at times.
And you have a great story about that.
There's one race you told Julie and I,
this story about that one race
where you were struggling with that, right.
You had the flu.
Can you tell that story?
I'll tell you two stories.
One, I mean quickly, the whole idea,
I mean, the race where I was just weak and I was sick
and I had the flu, didn't wanna compete,
didn't wanna swim, didn't think, and being a swimmer,
you play all these head games with yourself.
You wonder, am I gonna hit my taper?
You train a whole year hoping that you peak
at the right moment, only to drop
two or three-tenths of a second off your time.
And that was just for a year.
It's kind of insanity when you put it that way.
What were we doing?
I know, it's crazy.
It's like the payoff, the return on our investment.
I mean, we're being gypped.
Well, anyway, so I'm playing
with all these head games and all,
and I'm in the middle of the race
and at some point, again,
it came to that crossroad where it was, okay,
am I just gonna give into this moment?
Or am I gonna buy into the logical lies that I told myself?
And the answer was no, in that moment,
I allowed myself to give in to what I call now,
giving into your greatness.
We all have three people
in fighting for a position in our lives.
We can either be our average self,
we could be our defeated self,
or we could be our epic self.
And our epic self is the way that we do that is by learning
to give in to our own greatness.
And we do that in these little moments of decision.
And so in that race, I made that decision,
it was just a shift to allow,
again, not looking at the outcome,
not trying to will myself to win,
but instead recognizing that, you know what?
I have everything that I need in this moment
to accomplish what I'm called to do at this time.
That was the moment.
And the outcome was great,
I ended up winning
and getting my best time and everything.
But again, that was just one of those small moments.
And I was sick.
All the excuses that we had leaning into to the race,
I didn't have a great taper,
all these things existed, they were true,
but yet, still walked away with my best time
and walked away with the victory.
Yeah, and when you first told me the story,
I was so delighting because you had talked
about having all those facts
and the reality of the conditions.
And then at that moment you described it
that you just let go.
You dissolved into your greatness
and you felt something greater than yourself
actually come in and you won.
Against all logic, really.
So for somebody who's listening out there,
how do you do that?
You know what I mean?
There's a gap between
kind of intellectually understanding the story,
but what are the tools that you have to employ
to kind of free your mind up
to allow yourself to be in that headspace?
I definitely think that there comes a point
almost like the perfect storm that takes place where,
and you've heard the phrase,
when we prepare to do something,
so there's a process of ownership
and even getting to the opportunity
for great things to happen.
We all have to pay that price.
We all struggle with what I call the pluck
and the plop syndrome,
which is we wanna be plucked out of our current situation
and automatically plopped into our ideal situation
and all the while ignoring and forfeiting the process.
Well, we all have to go through that process,
the process of training,
the process of doing what we know we need to do
in order to be invited to the game,
in order to actually be in that position
to win or be in that position for great things to happen.
So that's one side of it.
You definitely do have to prepare
and preparing comes in many different ways.
Preparing is knowing what your strengths
and your gifts are and knowing how you operate.
Some people prepare in a very scheduled,
methodical kind of way.
Other people prepare in a very creative,
very random organic kind of way.
Yeah, I'm the former and Julie is the latter.
(Julie laughs out loud)
But the key
is so if we're gonna put this in the steps formula,
the first thing is identifying and owning
how you like to prepare and not making apology for it,
but owning how you prepare.
But then here's, I think the second step is recognizing
there comes a point where you have to trust
that you've done all that you can do.
And it's that moment, of trust
where this collision takes place
and providence moves with you,
meaning all sorts of things start to happen in your favor
that normally wouldn't,
if you didn't choose to allow yourself to let go.
So in swimming, we call it, it's swimming out of our mind.
We spend a lot of time trying to train
and mentally get prepared.
But at some point, we realize that now
we have to spend the next hour or however long
it takes us to get psyched up for our race.
What do we do?
We try to get out of our mind,
we put headphones on.
We do things to distract ourselves
because we no longer want,
after we've dotted the eyes, we've crossed the Ts,
we no longer want to question how we prepare.
And all we wanna do is is fight to be completely present.
And that's the second part,
is once we've prepared now the simple key is protecting
and guarding your present,
being completely present in that moment,
because that's when you invite
all of the other energy that takes place,
energy from people in the crowd yelling for you,
the energy of that fear that comes.
Fear is a beautiful thing,
fear and excitement come from the same source.
I mean, to just think, I hope I'm making sense.
I know I'm going-
No, absolutely.
It's perfect.
But fear and excitement come from the same source.
when we're in fear, biologically, what happens?
Our Palm starts to sweat, heart starts to beat fast,
eyes dilate, you get the dryness of mouth, cottonmouth.
Well, what happens when we're excited?
Our hands start to sweat,
our heart starts to beat fast, our eyes dilate.
The same chemical physical biological reaction
to fear is the same response to excitement.
The key is fear is the anticipation of something bad.
Whereas excitement is the anticipation of something good.
And so in that present, in the moment,
we must condition ourselves to embrace
what's going to be good
as opposed to embrace what could be bad.
Nice.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
Beautifully, eloquently put.
It's so inspiring to hear you speak.
Pastor Byron is preaching.
You do such a beautiful,
well, I mean, you're such a beautiful soul
and you're so connected spiritually,
and you have so much beauty and it's a delight.
Thank you, I wanna work with you.
How do I work with you?
Oh, that's funny, this is great.
This is great, this is awesome.
In swimming, in addition to the physical training,
there's a lot of visualization that you do,
you spend a lot of time kind of yeah, at a meet,
you're lying on a pool deck
and you're rehearsing your race.
Like every single detail,
every 10th of a second from beginning to end
of that 50 freestyle or whatever.
So that, by the time you get up on the blocks
it's a foregone conclusion,
it's almost robotic at that point,
the race is already done.
And Julie used to always say this to me
before the Ultraman races, it's already done,
you've already done it.
You just have to walk through it now,
but it's already complete.
And that is exactly what you said.
It's about being completely present and showing up
for the moment and allowing for the miracle to happen.
Yeah, and who's a master at this,
since we're talking swimming a little bit
and I've followed him
ever since he came on my radar is Michael Phelps,
a quick story I like to tell is I beat Michael Phelps.
(Julie and Rich laugh out loud)
Yes, I beat Michael Phelps.
He was 14.
He was a child.
He just burst in the sing,
it was the Santa Clarita International meet, invitational.
And I remember him, he got eighth,
he went and seated or he made the finals,
he was in lane eight.
And I was in lane six and beat him.
So that was my claim to fame.
I can say, I beat Michael Phelps.
But from that point, you knew that this kid was special.
And, of course, the rest is history.
He's been the most prolific athlete known to man,
arguably the best Olympic athlete of all time,
but he does something powerful and he dials it in.
And again, going back to that whole science of small wins,
in the book, "The Power of Habit" by Charles Duhigg.
Duhigg, yeah.
Exactly.
He talked about this, actually,
he talked about Michael Phelps
and basically, he says that Michael Phelps programs
into his daily rhythms, the small wins,
where he gets into a lifestyle of winning,
and everything, all these little wins lead up to his race.
So by the time he gets behind the block,
it's just another small win in this whole big momentum.
There's so much momentum
behind it.
That's so powerful.
Exactly, yeah.
And it's not just
within himself, it's everybody in the world who are already,
they're all going, he's already won it too.
The momentum has spread across the globe.
The hint in reality
is he's winning.
By all of that.
I mean, most people would look at it and go,
oh, my God, look at all the pressure on him.
he has to carry all that pressure
because everyone's expecting him to win,
but you're flipping it and saying,
no, it's actually everybody,
he has this huge monsoon of win behind him
where everyone's sort of already said,
okay, you're the guy, just follow through.
And when people show up to beat him,
again, whenever he is on the block,
everyone wants to beat him.
I mean, let's look at the Olympics in Beijing.
Okay, and the race, the 100 butterfly that he swam
with Michael Cavic against Michael Cavic,
who's also a great guy.
He was supposed to lose that race.
If you look at how the race,
if you look at all the replays,
you look at how Michael swam his race, perfect, to a T,
yet that momentum
that Michael Phelps had just was undeniable.
And he found a way to put his hand on the wall first.
I mean, that's powerful.
If it's on YouTube,
I'll post a link to the video of that race.
If you're like one of three people on the planet
who didn't see it.
It was the one race that he almost lost at that Olympics
where he kinda messed up his touch at the end
and Cavic almost nailed him.
And when you watch the repeats,
you really can't tell to the eye who won, like, what was it?
Was it a hundredth or a 200th of the second
or something like that?
It was something crazy, yeah.
But, of course, he won.
That's beautiful.
Yeah, that's amazing.
That's amazing.
So let's step back a little bit though.
'Cause I wanna get into your backstory.
You were not out of the gate,
nobody would've predicted that you were going to be,
this very bright, articulate,
upwardly mobile champion swimmer.
I mean, you grew up in Cleveland, yeah.
Kinda the wrong side of the tracks.
Let's hear a little bit about that.
Yeah, I grew up in the inner-city of Cleveland,
East Cleveland, Ohio.
I lived a few blocks away from Case Western Reserves
and for people who know where Case Western Reserve is,
it's right outside of downtown,
not in a very good neighborhood.
And the experts said, that I would be just another stat.
I, again, grew up in the inner city,
raised by a single black mom.
My dad, unfortunately, chose to sell drugs for a living,
but ultimately was found tied to his bed pole
shot six times in the head.
How old were you when that?
I was six and I'll never forget the day
that my mom brings me up upstairs.
And by the way, two weeks before, oh, I'm sorry,
two months before this happened,
my mom told my dad to leave, get outta the house,
because there was just bad elements
kept coming around the house.
And I've talked to her, of course,
as an adult and kinda got the backstory on all this.
But back then,
I just knew that my dad was moving into an apartment,
two blocks down the street from us.
And I didn't understand why but as a kid,
you're like, all right, I'll just roll with it.
And you were a single child.
Yeah, and so, no, I have a sister
who's six years older than I am.
And so that day I remember I was playing outside
with my best friend Lamar and we were out in the front lawn,
we used to have a tennis ball and then a broomstick.
And we would play bat or we would swing the bat, basically,
I would stand by the stairs
or someone would stand by the stairs,
and the other person would throw the tennis ball.
And you just, batting practice.
So we were having batting practice.
And I remember my mom calling me up upstairs
and she sat down, I'll never forget it.
We had this orange-like kind of love seat couch
that we had, she sat down in there, I sat next to her,
like kinda right between her legs.
And she said, "Hey, your dad's never coming back."
And in that moment,
I decided my first response was, okay,
I've become the man of the house.
And so my verbal response was we don't need him.
We don't need him.
We'll be fine without him, mom.
And no, she says, "You don't understand.
"No, he died.
"The police found him, and someone shot him."
And all of a sudden,
I just froze.
I didn't even cry, I just froze.
And I didn't actually cry until actually a year later,
but I just froze and I didn't know how to respond.
And then throughout that next year,
these little mini explosions would happen in my life,
and my stuttering increased.
Mini explosions like acting out or.
Yeah, acting out.
Getting in trouble,
Getting into trouble, getting into fights,
just not being a very pleasant kid and all.
But I just remember that time of being very confused
and hating my dad because he left us.
And I carried that ship on my shoulder through high school.
That's another thing, again,
the experts thought that I was gonna go down another path,
you know, finding swimming was a savior for me.
I mean, how did that happen?
It saved your life, right.
Swimming saved my life.
I credit the blessing and the gift of competitive sports
and swimming to really changing the angle
and the pitch of my life.
Well, one of the things that my mom did right out the bat,
she just became very devoted
to getting my sister and I out of the neighborhood
and used every excuse to do it.
I remember her kidnapping my friends and I on the Saturdays,
and we would literally go to the art museum.
We would go see the Cleveland Orchestra.
We would do all of these things
that kids in the hood didn't do.
And my mom found every excuse to keep us out of the hood.
And I remember, quick story,
how I fell into the sport of swimming,
'cause I literally fell into the sport.
Gray-Y, Euclid Y, which was a YMCA, that was across town,
created this program called Gray-Y.
And it was an initiative to use sports
to bridge the gap between the white poor kids
and the black poor kids who used to always fight.
And so you would come together in sport
and that's why they called it Gray-Y.
And so we started going to this Saturday and Sunday,
kind of activities in sports.
And there I was introduced to a lot of different sports.
The one sport that stuck was swimming,
but here's the crazy story real quickly.
My friend and I, Lamar, were playing,
we were just goofing off.
I didn't wanna play field hockey,
and so we decided to just kinda ditch that
and just hang out in the Y area.
And we started playing, you know,
we started hitting each other
and so he would hit me and start running around
and I would hit him.
And so basically, I remember hitting Lamar really hard
and he gave me that look like if I catch you,
I'm gonna kill you, kinda look,
you know, when you play you're kid,
you hit somebody too hard.
Well, we started running through the YMCA,
well, I run onto the pool deck.
I run and I run on the pool deck
and literally, almost slipped and fall into the water.
At the same time, the coach of the Euclid Y Dragonflies
comes over to me, I think I'm in trouble.
He starts telling me about how cool
and how great swimming is.
And I'm sitting here just wondering
when the hammer's gonna drop.
The guy when the kid's gonna show up,
beat your ass.
(Byron and Rich laugh out loud)
And he's talking, he's talking,
and he's telling me, long story short,
my mom comes to pick us up.
Jeff Armstrong, the coach ends up talking to my mom
about getting me involved in swimming.
And in that Monday,
I was on the Euclid Y Dragonflies swim team
and started swimming.
And that was at age nine.
That was when I was nine.
And I mean, swimming is such an unlikely outlet
whereas football, whereas basketball, why swimming?
And how does that happen?
Were there other black kids on the team?
No
It must have been
very unusual.
I was always a pioneer at the time.
And I could tell you thousands of stories about (laughs)
very funny stories about being black
back in the early eighties, in a competitive sports.
Yeah, then going to school
and feel like you do what?
Yeah, you swim, and believe me,
I got it from both sides
from the white kids who didn't see black swimmers
I became the authority of everything black.
So, I was the why do black people do this?
So I would get it from that side.
Do you know Colin Jones?
(all laugh out loud)
And then on the other side with all my black friends,
at this point, being in competitive swimming,
I disappeared from the neighborhood.
And so all my black friends were like,
where are you?
What are you doing?
And they would call me white boy.
And because at this time I was going through
to a speech specialist, a therapist,
because again, I stuttered, and when my dad died,
it really came out.
That was like a trauma
response to that.
A trauma response.
And also, my mom and the therapist always told me
to enunciate and really exaggerate as I pronounced words.
So all my black friends
and people in the neighborhood called me, white boy.
And so I had it from both ends,
but here's the thing, I knew I loved swimming,
I knew it because that was my creative zone.
Back then, I didn't know how far it would take me,
but all I knew at that moment, it was a refuge.
When I got in the water, I was in my playground,
I was in the element that just was beautiful to me.
And I also credit swimming for helping me
find what my learning style was.
Back then, in addition to stuttering
I was misdiagnosed as having ADD
'cause I couldn't stay still.
And I'm not the type of learner,
I mean, we know now
the whole different modalities of learning,
we know if you're auditory or kinesthetic or whatever,
back then I was not, I am to this day,
I'm not an auditory learner.
If you ask me to sit in a seat
and just listen to a professor or a teacher
for more than 30 minutes, it's done.
You're not gonna do it.
I'm not gonna do it.
It's not gonna get in.
So as a result I was kinda disruptive a lot in school.
Well, swimming, I recognized, wait a minute.
If you were to demonstrate to me how to do something
and then gave me an opportunity to actually do it,
I could pick it up like that.
I could intuitively pick it up.
And so swimming, I realized I started to excel
by the first year,
I was picking up all the different strokes
and I made it on the Zone Team.
And first, it was just swimming
fast enough to swim in different cities
and then different states.
And then I was invited to all these different meets
and I was like, "You know what?
"I'm gonna stick with swimming
"because swimming is getting me out of the neighborhood."
It's expanding your horizons.
And I'm going to nationals.
And all these different places.
And so I'm gonna stick with it.
And so I credit swimming for kind of finding my ultra
sort of thing, kinda discovering
that this is my love zone, my safe haven.
Well, it's also,
my story's a lot different from yours,
but I had certain sort of adolescent pains or whatever,
and swimming was always my safe place, it was my safe haven.
And there's something about being underwater
where none of that can touch you.
You know what I mean?
Like, you can't hear anything,
no one can talk to you and you feel safe.
it's almost like this womb-like place where you can go
and escape whatever unpleasant situations
surround you in your life outside the pool,
and for you to be able to recognize that
and lean into it.
Extraordinary story.
It's amazing, really,
set you on a completely different trajectory.
Yeah, it did.
Do you have friends
still from those days back there?
Are they still living back there?
Or do you keep in touch with any of those guys?
Well, since my adulthood and since I've been married
and since my grandmother died
and my mom moved out to Palm Springs,
I haven't been back to the neighborhood in over 15 years.
But I will tell you a story of the last time I was back.
I remember walking down the street,
it was in December, it was snow,
I was smelling just the whole Cleveland vibe is beautiful,
just kinda reminiscing through the hood.
All of a sudden I feel this thump,
this car approaching me
and music was-
The bass.
The bass that was happening.
And then I'm realizing, wait a minute, I'm in the hood.
And I haven't been here, people don't know who I am.
So I get a little nervous that this car is creeping.
I could feel that this car, they were looking at me,
so the car rolls up.
And then all of a sudden, the car rolls just right past me.
And when you grow up in the hood,
you learn that when you're in the city,
you don't walk on the sidewalk.
You never walk on the sidewalk.
You always walk in the street.
And the reason why you (laughs) it's like instinct,
you walk in the street,
not because you wanna just hold up traffic,
but that's the best shot of you running
if something breaks out.
If you're on the sidewalk, somebody can come and jump you,
or pull you in a alley or something.
You just learn to walk in the street.
So an instinct kicked in, I'm walking in the street,
all of a sudden, the car pulls up,
and then it just kinda pulls
and it stops right in front of me,
just kinda literally it doesn't go by me.
It turns, and now I have to purposely
walk onto the sidewalk to walk around it,
and so I realized, oh, hold on, so I stop.
And then the windows roll down
and I'm thinking I'm in trouble.
I am in trouble.
Well, it was (laughs) a good friend of mine.
We called him Deek, and I won't give his real name,
but he rolls down and he says,
"You are crazy, why are you walking in the hood like this?
"You could get shot."
And then I'm like, "Okay."
And all of a sudden,
I'm like in my twenties now, and we're all grown.
And I see Deek for the first time in ages
and I put two and two together,
Deek is now the head guy in the neighborhood.
He's a drug dealer.
And he's like, he owns this and he's like, "Man."
But he's your boy.
He's my boy,
he's my boy.
So I'm safe.
He's my boy, he's like, all right,
he says, "Yeah, yeah, you almost got shot."
(all laugh out loud)
And the funny thing, and he says, all right,
he says, "But don't worry, man.
"I got your back."
And he says, "If someone bothers you,
"tell 'em you know me."
And then he drives off.
And so (laughs) that was my last experience in the hood.
That's heavy.
And then what about the coach from that YMCA?
Ah, Jeff Armstrong, now it's so funny,
and this is the beauty about, I forget the poem,
but basically, ah, I wish I had it.
The poem, basically, it talks about
we all have to manifest our own greatness
because when we do,
the last part of the last sentence of the poem,
when we do, we give other people permission
to do the same thing, I just butchered that.
But you get it.
Well, here's the beautiful thing.
All the while, Jeff was one of those voices in my life
that just always, always encouraged me.
In fact, there were times where my mom holding down two jobs
and going back to school to be a registered nurse,
she was like, we can't swim this season.
Jeff would step up to the plate,
drive all the way to East Cleveland,
pick me up and take me to practice.
Yeah, phenomenal guy in my life.
Any case, he writes me a letter, I'm an adult now.
I'm an adult, Annette and I, we have our first son,
this is right after the 2000 Olympic Games.
I get a letter from Jeff Armstrong
and he writes me this long letter.
And I ended up calling him
and we talk over the phone and he says,
"Byron, you know, you really inspired me
"to get my life together."
And I'm like, what?
What are you talking about?
He said,
"Yeah, you came into my life at just the right time,
"and then to see how you progressed.
"It just really inspired me that I had no excuse."
And so I didn't know this at the time,
but he was just kinda doing his thing,
had a very, I forget what job he had,
but it didn't pay a lot.
But on a whim, he decided to be a volunteer coach at the Y,
and our paths crossed.
He followed my career, he encouraged me.
He invested a lot in me,
but once I graduated and went off to UCLA
and after the Olympic Trials in 96,
that inspired him to go back to school
and he got his degree.
And at that time where he wrote this letter,
he was running for a public office in
some town in Pennsylvania.
So he had really just turned his life around.
And it humbled me to know that,
wow, I didn't set out to do that.
I didn't know I had that impact when he was feeding me.
He was the guy I looked to and all,
but at the same time,
when we decide to live our best self,
and we decided to live our own epic life, so to speak,
you never know how that's gonna impact people.
And so when he wrote,
and we talked and he shared that with me,
that was just a very special, beautiful,
humbling moment in my life.
And at the same time,
when you're in service to another person
in the way that he was to you, so selflessly and amazingly,
he ends up benefiting from that as well.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
When you're in that service mode
and you're giving, you ultimately end up reaping the most.
That's an amazing story.
Just like, what does Mark Twain says?
He says, "How can you hand wash a piece of clothing
"without cleaning your own hands in the process."
It's the same thing.
And it's like when we serve
and we do it out of a pure heart and we do it
because that's the value we bring to the world,
our gift, all of us have gifts and talents.
And when we decide to give it away,
that's when our talents and strengths
become service to people,
that's when not only are we adding value,
it naturally comes back on you, it just happens.
Absolutely.
It's almost a universal law.
That's the way it operates.
And so, can you tell us a little bit
about how those experiences
and your experiences losing your dad as a child
and all of what you've just shared have shaped
the way you are as a father?
And tell us about your beautiful family
and your incredible children.
Oh, yeah, ah, I definitely feel that I've been blessed
in way beyond what I deserve.
My wife, of course, Annette Davis,
she was NC two A champion in volleyball,
made the Olympic team.
I definitely married up.
I always say that.
I always say that there's-
You got to.
Yeah, (laughs) I feel like a rock star
when she wears heels, she towers over me.
So we'll go to places and I know people think,
how did this guy get her?
So that's always cool.
I don't think that.
I don't think so.
You guys are pretty much a gorgeous family, all four of you.
Yeah, but she's been the anchor in our family
and we have two beautiful kids,
Maya, my 11-year-old.
And I have a daughter, Tori Victoria,
who's six, actually, she'll be turning seven soon
and just beautiful family.
And we ended up homeschooling.
We homeschool now.
And again, that's very unconventional
for the typical African American.
That's right.
Well, and that's been my inspiration
and she helped us greatly when we took the meet.
No, and your kids are amazing.
they're so poised in presence.
they're extraordinary.
It's very obvious that they're in good hands.
They're remarkable beings.
We have a lot of fun,
we have a lot of fun at the house.
And my son is challenging me now,
he's very creative and he has an entrepreneurial spirit.
And so it's cool to see how all this stuff
is just kinda working its way out
in his personality and his perspective,
'cause he's very methodical at that as well.
He's not, it kind of breaks my heart, but I love it.
I'm not the kinda dad who's like,
ah, he has to be an athlete or has to swim.
But secretly I'm wishing that he would embrace
his athletic genes but he doesn't care.
It never works that way.
He's not having it.
But definitely, my son right now
is definitely exploring his creative side.
He has already written three books, written three novels.
He's developing these characters
and he loves to sketch and draw,
and he has these cartoon characters
and the "Legend of Zano" is a book that he wrote.
That's amazing.
Yeah, and actually the stories
are really cool, very, very cool.
And so he's really exploring that.
And my daughter also, she's very athletic,
she has athletic genes but she doesn't care about athletics,
competitive athletics.
She loves dancing, she loves doing things.
Again, she's really competitive.
One of the little tricks that I play on her all the time,
I love it,
and it's gonna break my heart when she catches on,
but we'll be walking just somewhere random
and all I have to do is start running,
and she could be totally distracted.
And then once she sees me running,
she starts running just to beat me.
She doesn't know where the finish line is.
She doesn't know why we're doing it.
She just knows she has to win.
So great.
So she's that way.
But both Maya and Victoria have been huge blessings.
And it's really cool.
And Julie, you can relate to this.
You start to see as our kids start to really discover
who they are and start to really demonstrate
and express the layers and dimensions of their character,
and you see these little bursts of genius that take place,
and they're teaching you, and they're inspiring you
just in how they exist and how they play.
And that's what's going on right now in our household.
I'm seeing my son and my daughter approach challenges
and approach problems and are solving them.
And it inspires me.
And I take those lessons and weave them into stuff
that I write about, or that I use in my coaching sessions
but I'm learning it.
And I don't tell people that I'm learning it,
cats outta the bag now.
You told people.
Now you told people.
But that I'm learning it through the way
that my daughter approaches creative problem-solving.
And the way that my son just methodically
learns how to translate
and kinda reverse engineers how to do things.
It's been a cool-season right now in our lives,
in the Davis household.
That's amazing.
Well, just on that note too,
you know who inspires me and gives me hope with this,
this thing, if Maya and Victoria,
aren't gonna be the traditional organized sports athlete,
Laird Hamilton, you guys had Gabby on the show,
but he's one of those guys who totally does not,
he made a conscious choice not to be a competitive surfer.
He's taken the artistic
adventure explore track-
That's very interesting.
Of it, and it's like just the sheer expression
and the transformation and the personal discovery,
to him, those are the prizes.
And as a result, he continues to push himself
and then push the envelope on and reinvent the sport
and take it to new levels,
and I think that's what happens.
I think the creatives in whatever endeavor,
in whatever discipline,
whether it be in sports or business or whatever,
those who embrace their thirst for creativity
and expression, I think are the ones
who are the game-changers.
They're the ones who are gonna change the way
we do things in life.
So I'm thinking, okay, my son and my daughter
they're gonna be game-changers, maybe one day.
It's like that dude, Seth Godin, book, "The Icarus"
effect or whatever, have you read that yet?
Or checked that out.
So it's the same thing.
It's about sort of
transcending the traditional business structure and drone
and all of that, and embracing the creativity
and independent thinking within that construct
to push the envelope and take enterprises to the next level.
And we need more people like.
I mean, what we're missing is creativity
and creativity is what is going to pull us up
and really allow us to rise to a new level.
And so I think it's becoming more and more aware
that the school systems and what's out there
and what it's basically perpetuating
are professional educators and educated in what?
And how does that apply to life?
And so I will always support creativity,
above anything else,
because I trust in the greater design that each being
has a genius inside of it, every single one.
So if we approach children or all of us with awe and wonder
of show me who you are and show me how you were made
and what you have to express,
then we will all benefit from that to a great degree.
And I have to thank you and Annette
for really holding this vibration of excellence
in the home cooling category,
because when I really wanted to do it,
and Rich was having a lot of discomfort,
you guys were really catalysts
in allowing us to feel safe making that step.
And Annette really helped me because a lot of people think,
oh, you homeschool, wow, you're so organized.
And they immediately flash to a classroom set up
in your house with a blackboard and chairs and pointer.
And so, Rich was like, "You can't homeschool.
"You're not organized."
Or, "You're you're too creative, you're too flow."
And then Annette reminded us that,
if you're homeschooling,
you're going outside of that construct,
like if your child does well
in that then leave them in school.
But if you're homeschooling,
it's really sort of an open book.
And I'm sort of probably more on the other end
of the spectrum
because what I'm really doing is unschooling.
It's even sort of more free,
life provided the experience yesterday,
and that is that we came upon a barnel that had just died.
Somehow we don't know how,
and we made the decision that we would examine it
and measure the wingspan and look at it up close.
And then we actually made the decision to remove the wings
and the girls dug a grave and they did a prayer
and a ceremony and they offered
the body back into the earth.
And we have the fans, which are Sage fans
in the native American tradition,
that's a very sacred thing.
And, of course, that was our experience
of unschooling yesterday.
And it was inspiring and meaningful for all of us.
Yeah, I think that that's beautiful.
One of the things that I think society's catching up
and Stanford's actually leading the way
they've embraced the homeschooling process,
they have a curriculum.
Yay, Stanford.
It's amazing
how many Stanford courses you can do through,
iTunes U or whatever that are available online.
And it's powerful.
They're finding out that we are in and we all know this.
We're in an uncertain world
and our economy is constantly changing.
Business is changing with new technology
and how we interact and engage each other,
everything's changing.
The people who are able to take peace in the pocket
really embrace ambiguity and are confident
in how they're both their cerebral executive brain
meshes with the amygdala and the primal instinct of us,
how all those things really work together
to really drive us to new creation.
Those are the people who are again, changing the game.
They're the ones that we're looking to now for direction.
They're the ones who are solving problems
and are coming up with the solutions
that are helping, helping us,
set new courses in today's society.
There's enough momentum out there
where people are recognizing
that's how we need to really engage our kids.
That's how we need to prepare them.
We need to teach them how to think, dream, and create,
how to collaborate collectively as a creative unit,
but at the same time,
not sacrifice your own individuality,
and the uniqueness you bring to the table.
And when we work in environments,
dynamic environments like that,
that's when beautiful and magical things happen.
And we see it all the time.
We're seeing it right now
in different breakthroughs in technology.
And that's what excites me.
That's what excites me about the state
that we're in at this point.
Again, it's a tough economy
and we're all struggling
and we're all trying to figure it out.
But the hope that I have is that we are figuring it out.
And there are people who decide to embrace their ability
to combine their creativity
with a definiteness of purpose and spirit,
this resolve that makes them unstoppable
that we come to new breakthroughs and new solutions.
Right, it's all about living your epic life.
So let's talk about that.
So Before we get into that,
I'm going to have to say goodbye right now.
So anyway, it was be so beautiful seeing you,
please give my love to your family.
And I wanna be a part of the Epic program
and I wanna work with you,
and so I'm gonna be calling with all the other listeners.
Oh, awesome.
Here, let me give you a hug.
All right, babe, see you in a while.
So, Live Your Epic Life,
which is Byron's website and his program.
So I wanted to talk a little bit
about what that's all about.
Like what is it?
How do you get involved?
What are you gonna get out of it?
Well, Live Your Epic Life,
liveyourepiclife.com is a ongoing experiment in the realm
of infinite possibility
if I can give any more of a vague response,
basically, in a nutshell, is I wanna empower
and challenge people to live their legend
and ultimately leave a legacy.
Where did this desire
to try to empower people come from?
I mean, is this as a result of?
We didn't even talk about this,
but you have a background as a pastor
and you, obviously, have this past that informed
all of this kind of thing.
Where is this drive coming from?
I think initially it just comes from the conviction
and belief that I truly believe
that God didn't make a mistake when he made us.
And all of us are uniquely gifted
with a gift mix of stuff that will then allow us
to bring and create new,
value-added contributions to this world.
I definitely believe that, I truly believe that.
And if I look back or when I look back on my life
and I see there's a common thread in theme,
no matter where life took me and what season I was in
or what job I did, the common denominator
was always me wanting to get the best out of myself
and the most outta my life, really tinker kinda be my own,
I always say I'm in constant beta,
we're all in constant beta mode.
So really trying to get the best outta myself,
and when things didn't work out really going inward
and examining, okay, what was the inner breakdown?
So always being a student of human dynamics
and just my own performance
and trying to get the best outta myself,
and then two, even more so feeling even greater satisfaction
when I inspired or empowered
or challenged someone else to do it,
I was always a better relay swimmer
than I was an individual swimmer or in individual races.
Not because I just I didn't like to swim individual races,
it was something about being a part of that team
that team dynamic that allowed,
just got me more excited about doing
whatever it is we were doing.
So I've always enjoyed coming alongside people
who had a desire to experiment and transform.
And so that was a constant theme in my life,
and I have reached that season in my life, Rich,
where now that's what I want to do for the rest of my life
is I want to constantly explore and experiment
and really embrace this transformation process for myself,
but then also work with other people who have
and share the same kinda conviction.
For somebody who is interested in exploring this
what are they in for?
Without trying to say that I have this,
four-step program.
Here's the four steps dude.
But I do, I think there is a methodology
behind transformation and growth
and how to lean into it and embrace it.
Basically, I believe the knack for us
when we study great performers,
I call 'em high-impact people.
When we study high-impact people,
no matter what discipline or industry or sport,
we see that they intuitively do three things very well.
They see what they want clearly,
they learn to express what they want fully.
And here's the third one that most of us miss,
they learn how to let their obstacles lead the way,
I call it illumination, seeing what you want clearly,
animation, expressing what you want fully,
and then iteration,
allowing to let your obstacles actually lead the way.
What does that mean?
Allowing your obstacles lead the way.
Buckminster Fuller,
great mathematician.
Sure.
He keeps coming up on the podcast.
It's like the third time Buckminster Fuller has come up.
That's awesome.
He says a problem well defined
is a problem well on its way to being solved.
When we allow our obstacles to lead the way
we learn to embrace obstacles and setbacks and roadblocks,
not in the way of fatalism,
meaning that's it, I'm done,
but more so recognize that roadblock
is asking for us
to respond to the situation in a different way.
And when you fully understand it,
you can identify like,
this is exactly what's holding me back
this particular robot, as opposed to, I don't know why
I can't move forward, not knowing,
but when you know exactly what it is,
then that's the first step
towards trying to come up with the solution
to attack and overcome it.
Yeah, but the roadblock is telling you what to do next.
Your immediate next move is to move around the roadblock.
It's like this,
it's like if we're in a dark room and we wake up
and let's say we're in a hotel, making this up,
we're in a hotel room, dark and all,
but we wanna go to the bathroom.
Well, we get up out of the bed,
number one, we never question whether or not
we're gonna get to the bathroom, right.
But it's dark, we can't see a thing.
What do we do?
We stumble our way to the bathroom, right.
We kinda walk and we kinda feel where the end table is,
we kinda notice our hand on the wall.
All of a sudden,
these little obstacles start to actually create
when we weave them together,
a reliable roadmap that brings us to our destination.
That's what obstacles and challenges do in our life
is that they are not roadblocks,
but if we know how to use them right, they become reliable,
very pragmatic roadmaps
to really giving us what it is we want,
the result that we want.
So, all right.
So you have these three things,
these cornerstone principles to your program.
And is this like an online program?
Or do you do personal coaching?
Explain to me exactly what it is that this all entails.
There are three different kinda on ramps to this road,
and, again, I call these three things rhythms.
And what I do in a nutshell is I help people practice
these three rhythms in their life,
practice illumination, animation, and iteration,
as it relates to their desired outcome.
And one, there's a lot of free resources on the blog,
liveyourepiclife.com
that has evolved over the last six months especially,
doing a lot of interview with experts,
but then also diving deep on each of these things.
So that's the first step.
The first on-ramp is just hanging out at the blog.
There's a life planning guide that I give away,
basically, it's your epic life plan,
and it's a step by step guy that helps people get clear
about what the kinda results they want
in each area of their life.
And then how do you create a narrative
or a story that you can now step into in order
to live that life out.
So that's the first step.
And then it goes all the way up
we just launched, in fact, the doors are closed for this.
We just actually launched the Unstoppable U Bootcamp today,
we'll open that up in the spring again,
but that's where I take a small group of people
through a process of really embedding these rhythms
in the context of their life.
How do we really start to see what we want clearly?
And I'm gonna go off on a tangent a little bit,
what I mean by that?
Seeing what it is you want clearly,
and we've all experienced this intuitively,
all we have to do is really analyze
when we've succeeded at something
you can see these components.
When we learn to see something clearly,
what we've learned to do intuitively or by design
is translate a future desired outcome
into its present-day equivalent
or present-day approach to doing life.
If I set out to lose 60 pounds
in the next 90 days, or whatever,
90 or 60 pounds lost, three months from now,
looks completely different in the present moment.
And it's when you start to see, well, losing weight,
90 pounds lost three months from now,
looks like
a new type of diet,
a restrictive calorie, a high nutrient, low-calorie diet,
being able to engage in exercise that allows us
to, again, expend more energy than we're taking in.
And then the proper rest and fluid intake of water,
not drinking our calories
and I'm being generic in the whole description.
But, well, once we start to map out
what the desired outcome
looks like in our present day approach to doing life,
that's when we see what it is we want clearly,
and then we're able to express what we want fully.
Now we have the plan, we have the roadmap,
we know what we need to do.
Now, we can now give ourselves, we can animate,
we can express ourselves through engaging
in those activities.
I always say that discipline,
my definition of discipline is demonstrating
a clear decision on a daily basis.
Once you see what it is you want clearly now,
all you do is demonstrate that decision on a regular basis,
on a daily basis, that's expressing fully.
And then throughout the way, your plans are plans,
no matter how well thought out they are,
they're never perfect.
They have to be modified, they have to be adjusted.
There are so many variables in life
that we can't account for,
many times, we are going to have to make midcourse
corrections along the way.
And so that's where the ability to iterate on the fly
and incorporate that into your rhythm, your lifestyle,
that's where the magic happens,
because that's when you become unstoppable.
But essentially what you're saying
is you're creating a calculus and a methodology
for transformation and breaking it down into components
that are digestible and understandable,
and rooting somebody in the present
and in accordance to a plan to get somebody
where they wanna go.
Exactly,
exactly.
That's great.
What do you think is the primary thing
that holds people back?
I say this all the time,
but people say, oh, people don't change, they don't change.
And it's like, yeah, they do.
You change, it's not easy.
And usually pain is the motivator (chuckles),
when your back is up against the wall
and you have no other choice, then you can change.
But willfully and voluntarily changing to grow and expand
it's the big challenge that everybody wants
and people just struggle with the most.
And what do you think is holding people back?
Well, of course, the proverbial
and the popular answer is fear.
We're all afraid at some level,
but let's just kinda dissect that a little bit.
I don't think it's really the fear that holds us back.
I think it's finding out the truth
that really holds us back.
I think all of us, at certain points in our life,
we have a romantic vision of how things are to play out.
And whenever we wanna embark on something,
something that we've never done before,
we automatically have this, again,
we have a vision or this idea of the way things should be,
and whenever we start to now pursue that,
we start to recognize and experience the way things are.
And when the way things are don't immediately match up
to the way things should be, all of a sudden,
we get uncomfortable, we get disappointment.
That's when doubt, discouragement, distraction,
all these things start to flood into our life.
And we end up protecting that idea in our head
and it's safe there, again, it's safe there, we control it.
And we fall in love with the idea
of doing something unique,
something great, something exciting,
but we're not willing to go through the process
of wrestling through the way things are as we manifest
or as we start to bring that into volition.
So I definitely believe that fear is a factor,
but we can use fear as a tool,
like you said, fear is a gift,
I said that earlier fear is a gift.
And so it's not about being afraid of something, embrace it.
Yeah, everyone's gonna be afraid the first time
and the first few times we try things,
everyone's gonna fail the few times we try things.
Failure is a part of the process.
So let's retool fear into excitement.
Let's start focusing instead of anticipating
that negative outcome.
Oh, you know what?
I'm finding evidence that what I think should happen,
isn't going to happen.
So I'm gonna stop.
No, let's start, you know what?
I get a clear picture of what could happen,
but I'm not gonna own that.
I have no control over that.
But what I do have control over
is doing what I can with what I have, right where I am,
and then allowing the process to unfold,
knowing that I will be able to solve the problem
as it comes about.
And so we embrace the journey
and really accept our present state of reality.
When we can get comfortable in embracing the moment,
embracing challenges as they come,
then we start to build that whole winner's momentum.
We start to recognize that, you know what?
I can solve that problem.
Or, you know what?
There's a resource that I've always taken for granted,
or I've ignored that's right in front of me,
let me use this.
And pretty soon we find ourselves being catapulted into,
or across the finish line with our desired outcome.
Right, but I think getting
at the fundamental starting line of the whole thing,
in order to trigger that excitement,
or to even come up with any kind of trajectory,
you need to know what you want.
Like, what is it that you want?
And I think that a lot of people don't know
and then they're ashamed that they don't know,
like there's a lot of people that say,
I don't even know what I wanna be when I grow up,
or I don't even know,
I know I'm not satisfied
but if I had to pick my ultimate career,
I don't even know what that is.
And then they feel bad because they think they should know.
And there's sort of a disassociation from the self.
Well, let's call the big elephant in the room out here,
really, what's wrong with not knowing?
Again, I think in our Western culture,
we learn and it becomes ingrained in us
that we have to have this solution
or the answer before we begin,
but yet life doesn't play out that way.
And so if you're starting at a point
where you really don't know,
well, then that's the first obstacle.
What can we learn from it?
Well, let's explore what the possibilities
and the opportunities that are available,
that then start to resonate with your strengths
and your passions.
And so the first step in most people,
the first step that most people have to go through
is stepping into a discovery process.
Robert Green, in his book, he just came out with a mastery,
talks about there's a phase of apprenticeship
that every master goes through.
And if you ignore this apprenticeship process,
then you keep yourself stuck and not really discovering,
and then therefore honing
what your passions are because having a passion
is not gonna pay the bills.
But taking it a step backwards,
some people don't even know what they're passionate about.
And I think a lot of that
is because everything is so cheap right now.
It's so easy to buy distractions.
So everybody's watching TV and playing video games
and staring at their cell phones.
And we are almost by design
in this constant state of distraction from ourselves.
And I think when that's perpetuated,
we do get into this disassociated state of being
where it's like, I don't even know
what I'm passionate about.
There's a lot of people walking around,
you say, well, embrace your passion.
well, how do I even know what I'm passionate about?
Well, and that's where the whole
apprenticeship process comes in.
I call it giving yourself room to play and experiment,
most of the time, because we pack our lives
with all these distractions as you eloquently pointed out.
I think that's so true that we fool ourselves into thinking,
we don't have enough time to play and experiment.
It's only when we allow ourselves the room,
the space to become an apprenticed,
it gets harder as an adult, as we get older
and we move into and we operate in this professional zone,
the older we get,
the more we're supposed to know what's going on.
And so the more we like to hide the fact
that we really don't know what's going on.
So it's easy, we get into that momentum,
we get into that mindset that then keeps us stuck.
What we have to do is learn to embrace
the apprenticeship mindset,
and technology and the resources
are available to us in our fingertips.
We can have virtual mentors
and create our own apprenticeship instantly,
all we have to do, and this is the key,
this is how you discover your path passion.
Even if you don't know what your passion is,
here's how you discover your passion,
allow yourself to care more than normal
and more than necessary about an activity.
And then when you allow yourself to care more than normal,
about something and more than necessary,
you start to move out of the realm
of being your average self.
You start to step into that fanatical realm
of let me really explore and really chase this rabbit hole
to see how far it really goes,
all we have to begin doing is just caring about it more
than the average person,
and what that does is start to unfold.
You'll find out very quickly whether or not
something grabs your heart or resonates with you or not,
you'll find it.
And if it doesn't, cool, guess what?
You move on to something else.
And if that doesn't work, great,
you move on to something else.
The value in that discovery process is that,
again, God doesn't waste time in our lives,
whatever process we go through,
we will discover something that leads us to ultimately
what it is we really want,
but we've gotta be willing to move down that process,
we've gotta be willing to be an apprenticed.
And then I would also add to that,
many people say, in fact,
a guy that I was coaching said something
that was just authentic.
He asked this question in just very, very pure innocence.
He says, "Byron,
"what if you desire to do something
"that you really don't believe you can do?
"You don't have the confidence,
"you don't believe that you can actually do it."
And it was a great question.
And the short answer is this,
you learn how to, number one,
discount your own voice in the process.
Okay, that's a step one
because you really don't have the authority
or the credibility-
To make that judgment call.
To make that judgment
because you failed at it so far, you haven't done it.
So you can't make that judgment.
So logically, if you wanted to know something
about financial investing and you had an opportunity
to learn under Warren Buffet
or learn under someone who's tried really hard,
but hasn't gotten the results you want.
Who would you choose?
Warren Buffet, right.
You would wanna do that.
So in this case, in this scenario,
when you really realize
that I don't know how to do something,
and I don't really think I can,
you've gotta recognize in that moment
that you're not the Warren Buffet in the situation,
you are the other person.
You're not in a place to even objectively judge
whether you can or cannot do that.
Exactly, exactly.
So why be unfair to yourself in that?
And the second step is, so once you acknowledge that,
you know what?
I've gotta discount my own judgment,
my own belief in this situation,
the second step then is to submit yourself,
become obedient to a proven process.
So now you have to now
give your trust and your faith over to a proven process.
So that's when you seek out, who's doing this?
Who's gotten the results that you need to get?
If you think, well, I'm not musically inclined,
I've no musical talent.
I'll never be able to play the piano or whatever
and then saying, well, I'm gonna go to this teacher.
And I will apprentice to this person
who has taught many people how to play the piano.
It's a proven procedure and process that I can undertake.
Yeah, and we know this as athletes,
there comes a point where we have to buy
into the culture and the methodology
of the program we're in.
If we don't buy into how the coach is preparing us,
then we'll second guess our preparation.
And then we'll lose all confidence in our ability.
There comes a point
where you have to give your trust over to the process.
You have to fall in love with the process.
You have to give your heart to the process.
Again, you've gotta care more than normal
and more than necessary.
And then what takes place
is you suspend your disbelief long enough
that you then invite new experiences
that give you better results
from which you can then base better and stronger beliefs on.
So your beliefs ultimately will catch up to your experience,
and that's where confidence comes from.
And it all goes back to trying to propel
some of this moment that we were talking about earlier.
And so I'm not a advocate of just pump yourself up
and muster off enough confidence to do something.
Well, it brings false.
It's not backed up by anything.
It's pretending.
Allow yourself to embrace,
it's like this,
so when I speak to athletes
and I go out and talk, I say,
at times you will not be confident.
Recognize that, embrace it.
Don't be surprised if, and when it happens,
confidence has very little to do
with your capability of actually doing it, making it happen.
In that moment, don't worry about not being confident.
Allow yourself to be curious.
We can all be curious.
We can all allow ourselves to go into a moment
into a situation where we don't know the answer,
we acknowledge we don't know the answer,
but we all can embrace that and be very curious.
And when we're curious, it's just like a kid.
When you're curious about something,
you put on the hat of a professor,
your awareness, and in all of your energy,
your brain power starts to become acutely aware
of scenarios, of patterns, of little answers,
all these things start to now come at you
when you decide to be curious,
you invite enough room to create experiences
that then you can start to stack up,
that will become your confidence.
So you don't have to be confident.
You don't have to believe you can do something
in order to do it,
just allow yourself to be curious enough
to move through that moment and that period of ambiguity,
and then allow the small incremental results
you get to dictate your mid-course corrections
so that ultimately you will cross the finish line.
Right, and that confidence
will come as a result of that.
It's sort of acting as if, it's like,
I don't believe this is gonna work,
but I'm gonna show up and do it anyway.
And then over time this sort of objective feedback
becomes undeniable that, oh, actually I can do this,
or I proved myself wrong.
And I always talk about this too,
it's sort of understanding that (clears throat)
your mind is not always your friend.
And when it's firing signals off saying you can't,
or I stink or I'll never be good or whatever,
those are just messages, and that you have a choice,
your higher self has a choice to give those credence
or to dismiss them and say,
hey, that's interesting that my brain
is trying to tell me that I can't do that.
But I'm just gonna shrug that off
and not pay attention to that because I know better,
or I choose to believe otherwise or act differently.
Yeah, I call that our inner-child.
Our inner-child will start acting up
and be rebellious.
But as the adult in the situation who has-
You have smack 'em down. (laughs)
You say, well, no, I'll demonstrate it.
I'll show you, take my hand, and I will lead the way,
in those moments when our defeated self
or when our average self want to take the lead in our life.
No, that's when our epic self has to say,
you know what?
I'm going to lead the way.
And we allow ourselves enough room to fail,
embrace that, because we know that, again,
that's the whole idea of iteration.
We recognize that, you know, my failure in 1996,
wasn't the end of my life,
but I was able to ultimately use that failure
to set up future success in different areas of my life.
Likewise, that's the attitude and the inner-culture
we have to embrace in order to really do things
that are meaningful in our life.
And I know I'm throwing a lot or going off on tangents here,
but it's for the same reason why I'm not
an advocate of setting goals,
the way we've always been taught in school.
I'm not an enemy to setting goals,
but I think we limit ourselves a lot
when we get trapped in the need to set goals.
What I do believe in is not setting goals
is not a license to not just do anything in life.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about actually learning how to engage vision.
So learning to stop setting goals and start engaging vision.
What that means is learning how to own a process
and a plan in our life.
Many of us are afraid to make a choice,
make a decision because we're afraid
that decision will be wrong.
So we settle into this idea
that I don't know what my passion is.
What we're really saying is,
is I'm not willing to make a decision to draw a line
a definite line.
I think that's very true.
That's interesting.
And go with this good, bad or ugly,
but it's only when we decide
to make that definitive decision,
will we find out and we'll find out quickly
whether or not it was the right or wrong decision,
but if it turns out to be the wrong decision, that's okay.
Right, to give yourself permission
to make the wrong decision.
I think that goals are they have their place
in the sense that they create that structure
for people who operate well
within that kind of a paradigm like myself.
But I think you're correct,
and that what happens with goals
is that not only are they limiting
because you're putting a cap on it
and are you the best objective decision-maker to decide
what you're capable or not capable of, probably not.
And secondarily, they tend to be very destination oriented
instead of journey oriented,
so it's sort of all about the obvious example
is always the weight loss example.
Like I wanna lose 10 pounds
or I wanna lose 50 pounds,
and it's all about getting to that day
or crossing the finish line at that marathon
or whatever it is.
But then it's sort of the questions never asked
like, well now what?
You get there
and then you have the sort of what am I supposed to do now?
And then the kind of weird emotions that swirl around,
what happens next?
Because it was all about getting to that endpoint,
as opposed to being actively engaged in the moment
and in the destination and in the journey.
And even you hear it all the time,
people that achieve these goals,
whether it's an Olympic gold medal or whatever it is,
they'll always tell you,
well, thinking back on everything it took for me
to get there is where the best memories
are and where I really can engage the joy
was in that process and in the journey.
Yeah, and while I definitely believe
that the magic and the beauty
and the nectar is in the journey,
like you, I am a results guy, I like to see results,
but I also think that let's live a life that's prolific
as opposed to goal-oriented.
And what I mean by that is being prolific is establishing
a rhythm of life where we're accomplishing stuff,
meaningful stuff, stuff that matters on a regular basis.
When we think of Steven Spielberg or Stephen King,
we think these guys are prolific.
They keep coming out with great stuff over and over again,
for them, it's not about the goal,
for them, their work is just a snapshot
of their expression of their existence.
And before they finish one thing,
they're off to doing another,
and so it's that perpetual journey
that produces results is what I'm after.
That's living prolifically.
That that's what we want.
And guys will tell you, people will tell you, again,
after a big event, after the Super Bowl,
why is it that we hear story and story after story
of people doing something great?
And then immediately short time afterward,
they blow their brains out,
or they go off on the deep end or something.
And we're like, how did that happen?
It's because partly they got themselves
so wrapped up in defining who they were in that moment,
when the moment was gone,
if they didn't immediately have another hill to conquer,
they were lost.
Well, I say, let's not limit ourselves by that.
Let's have definite checkpoints.
Let's have moments where we can celebrate victory,
I'm totally into that.
But instead, let's create a lifestyle
and a culture within ourselves where we're producing
these things on a regular basis.
It's basically, just a constant manifestation
of who you are.
So as opposed to, yeah, I'm gonna win the Super Bowl,
or if your Spielberg it's just, this is what I do,
I'm doing it all the time, I'm onto the next thing.
And you're not overly attached
to the result of any one thing,
because that's not your focus,
your focus isn't crossing the finish line at the marathon
or what the scale says that day.
It's just, this is what I do now.
This is who I am, and I'm constantly expressing it.
It's a completely different perspective on the whole thing,
but yeah, that's very interesting.
Very good, yeah.
Cool.
Live prolifically.
Yeah, let's live a pro-
Live your epic life.
Live our epic life.
And here's the thing,
the reason why I say epic,
I know for some, that's kinda over-the-top,
live your epic life,
that's birthed out of the, again,
the conviction that we all have a story to tell in our life,
and every epic tale, whether we read it or in a book
or watch it in a movie has three main elements.
You have a flawed main character
who decides to embark on some type of ambition,
who ultimately must come up against an antagonist
or conflict in order to do so.
And it's in that process that the person's story plays out
that a transformation has to happen that ultimately allows
them to position themselves, to actually accomplishing
what it was that they once thought was impossible.
And what I believe is what makes for a great and epic story
also makes for an epic life.
Well, we all have that story,
it's this Joseph Campbell, "Hero's Journey,"
and it's incumbent upon all of us to be the hero
in our own movie.
You know what I mean?
Stop being an extra,
or a supporting actor in your own biopic.
Well said, yeah, exactly.
And we all have that power within us.
We all have that power and it does require a decision.
And it doesn't mean that it's easy
and it's not about buying a book
that's gonna give you the three steps
where you're not gonna have to do anything
and your life's gonna change
and you're gonna lose weight and all that kind of stuff.
You have to take personal responsibility for it.
But if you're willing to do the work and take direction
and engage in this apprenticeship,
which is sort of a lost art form in which we all used
to kind of grow up within the construct
of that's kind of gone away.
But I think because technology is becoming so predominant
as a part of our economy and so specific
that's really coming back, you know what I mean?
If you wanna be a film editor,
you have to apprentice with a film editor,
you can go to school and learn the software program,
but I think that you're seeing a resurgence of that.
And I think that that's a good thing.
It's like when I went and worked in a law firm.
Yeah, I had partners and senior associates
that I reported to, but it wasn't an apprenticeship,
there wasn't like one guy who said,
I'm gonna teach you how to do this
and you're gonna follow me around and do everything I do.
You know what I mean?
And I think that we could all benefit
from having more of that in our lives.
And we could all benefit from having a support system,
a strong mother who believed in you
and a Jeff Armstrong at the YMCA,
who went the extra mile to look out for you
because he believed in you.
And so I think we all need to look at ourselves
and at our own lives and say,
who is that person for us?
And who can I be that person for?
You just said something, man,
that's I think, magic, powerful.
There are situations and people out there right now who,
when they honestly look at their life,
they don't have that person.
They don't have a mom who's totally sold out
to investing in them.
They don't have that person who was a champion for them,
if and when they didn't believe in themselves.
Yeah, they are, but here's the key.
And I go back to, you jarred this in my mind,
my eighth-grade teacher always said
the fastest way to master or learn anything
is to turn around and immediately teach it to someone else.
Well, you can reverse engineer the whole apprentice process,
where all, again, you just decide that,
you know what?
I am going to teach or invest in someone else
and show them, demonstrate to them
how to get results in this area of your life.
And if you just do that, if you just even start there,
have the courage to start there, all of a sudden,
you will start out of the woodwork,
resources and relationships
and things you used to take for granted
that you look at at a different way,
will then become your teacher,
that they will become your source of content and information
that now starts to funnel through you.
And in the process of you just inviting someone else
along the process with you,
you begin to practice the very thing
you once thought you couldn't do.
So really learning,
and if you don't have anybody
that you can think of right off the top of your mind,
that's your champion and all that,
that's no excuse to not immediately turn around
and invest yourself, put yourself on the line,
call yourself to the carpet and say, you know what?
I don't quite know how to do this yet,
but I am committed to showing
and demonstrating someone else the best approach to do it.
And just putting yourself in that position immediately,
all of a sudden, you now become this honing device
where all these resources and all of the information
you need will start to come together for you,
and in the process of you sharing, you giving yourself,
you pouring yourself into someone else,
you benefit in the process.
Yeah, absolutely.
That's something I learned a long time ago
and is a key cornerstone in recovery,
essentially that, if you're feeling stuck or you're unhappy,
or you get wrapped up in your story of why your life
isn't the way you want it to be?
Or you're getting all sort of,
what's the word for it?
Just sort of self-defeating
and running these patterns in your brain,
you can't think your way out of that,
you've gotta act your way out of it.
And the best way to act your way out of it
is to reach out to somebody and be of service to them.
Whether it's somebody who's less fortunate than you,
or it doesn't even matter the form
in which the service takes.
It's the simple act of doing that,
that gets you out of yourself, and into somebody else.
And there's something magical about that.
That will shift not just your perspective,
it will shift your energy, it will shift your life.
And suddenly you start to forget about your problems
and there's a joy in that.
And you will always end up reaping more
than you are giving every time.
It's like this weird spiritual equation.
Yeah, and not only that,
there's science to back that up as well.
Because as we begin to practice,
again, express ourselves, animate,
do these different things.
We now start to engage and call on our nervous system
to fire off in new and different ways
and create new neural pathways that ingrain new behaviors
and new responses to external stimuli or to triggers.
So what used to trigger a certain behavioral pattern
now triggers a more empowered behavioral pattern.
And so all that starts to happen when again,
we allow ourselves to pour into others.
And again, we hear it in different language in business,
and Seth Godin's a big proponent of this,
when you start to deliver value,
when you start to give away your best stuff,
all of a sudden, what happens?
People start to see you as the trusted authority.
And pretty soon,
even though they could get the same stuff from someone else,
they choose to get it from you.
Well, in the process of you doing that you begin
to own being that trusted authority
and everything now starts to become second nature.
So what happens in business
also can happen in every context, in every area of our life.
Amazing.
Hope that makes sense.
No, it does, man.
I think that's a great place to start too.
How long?
Well, we've been going for two hours.
Oh, wow.
(Byron and Rich laugh out loud)
We gotta sew it up.
I think we did it, though.
Oh, this has been awesome.
This has been a lot of fun
How do you feel?
I feel good.
You wanna get anything off?
Well, you know what?
I feel like jumping on the bike and running.
I'm pumped right now.
Me too.
I'm gonna go run.
Yeah, I think I got my bike right over there.
You wanna borrow it.
(laughs) I might have to.
So yeah, this is fantastic.
Thank you so much for your time.
Rich, thank you.
It's really great
to have you, man.
And I'm a better man for having you in my life.
Man, I just wanna tell you,
I know there's a lovefest right now,
but you and your story inspire me so much.
Just your story of "Finding Ultra" inspired me
to get off my butt and do my first "Iron Man."
Right, that's right, man.
You definitely walk the talk brother, so thank you.
All right, thanks, buddy.
(calm head-bobbing music)